when you finish a screenplay what do you
do well that's a good question um I
usually take a nap really no I do I do I
don't I don't go out and do anything
crazy like celebrate I just I get I get
very happy and I'm like yes and I send
it off and I usually go take a nap
because especially when I'm in that last
stretch where something is either do or
I'm almost done that's when I start
getting a little like super anal where
I'm going back through everything and
I'm paginating the pages and you know
one of the tricks I learned is like you
know to try to have you know the last
line of it on a page be something where
they have literally make it a
page-turner where they have to turn the
page to see what the next page is gonna
be like that was a trick I learned from
a friend of mine and so you know I try
to go through and make sure like unless
it's the very end of is a really great
saying that it like every end of every
page is something where you have to flip
the page to at least finish it because
you get them over the next page they're
probably gonna keep reading it's like if
you stop them at the end of a page with
something like but they may not turn the
next page so you know I do all those
like after I've worked on the script
itself then I do those like little like
you know mine gave me things so like
make sure it's a page-turner so by the
time I'm ready to send it off and I have
to go back to one more time and have you
know then I take a nap cuz I've wore
myself a hot also - is it a sense of
accomplishment where you feel like okay
I can rest now yeah
I'm sure like up until a certain
deadline it might be a lot of sleepless
nights or maybe not it's nice and it's
stress but ya know when I when I finish
something there is definitely a sense of
accomplishment where you're like yes
especially if you if you know it's good
you know if you're not sure then it's
kind of like send with your fingers
crossed but I'm still gonna go take a
nap but then it's like but um but yeah
when you feel like you really nailed it
it's good but that's again the
interesting about the business is you
can do a script that you're a hundred
percent confident in and your producer
loved it and then but one person in the
studio region is like me anything like
so again it's a rollercoaster ride it's
really you know that's why again I'm
very big on people like doing their own
content and trying to you know do your
own content because that's if you really
want to ensure something
it's made done the way you ride it
that's the best way to do it but but
yeah there's it's very very gratifying
when you type the end and you mean it
and you can hit Send with whoever you
have to turn the script over - so it's
you definitely feel like good job so if
you're not a writer for hire for
something it's your own like passion
project and you finish it then what's
your process then I usually try to you
know then I'll send it to you know my
agent or manager to look at and then you
know figure out like what place is this
into - or now what I've started doing
really because again I'm getting more
into like producing my own stuff is you
know connecting with some people that I
think have access to invest you know
more than into more the business side of
it like okay well this might be good for
this company these companies so let's
try to you know attach somebody or let's
try to you know now I've gotten more
business-minded I'm in the last couple
of years especially because um again
it's really you know I'd love to someday
be at the point where I'm running my own
company where I have like assistants I
can read a bunch of scripts - and like
we can make a whole bunch of movies
about you know right now it's like a you
know I I have some some good stories
that I want to tell and something like
all right I got to maximize the chance
to get those made so that means if it's
something that I've written on my own a
lot of times in Latin now I'm going out
and looking for independent financing as
opposed to trying to get it set up
somewhere so that's been a fun like
learning experience in the last year or
so
you